[Musique]
fils ça c'est beurk terre de tes grands
parents et de leurs grands parents avant
te mets tout là-bas par delà les
contrées lointaines se troue le monde
des dragons
et je crois que ta destinée c'est qu'un
jour tu trouves ce monde caché tu sais
que ma jambe s'étend à jojo c'est ça que
tu veux aller
et je fais comment pour descendre est
mon groupe a droit
[Musique]
il est donc pas le faire
et le ce
[Musique]
notre furie nocturne
c'est plus un furie brion suri est clair
c'est mieux c'est plus classe comme non
pas mal il ya toute une armada avec
assez de cash pour enfermer tous nos
dragons
c'est un ennemi d'un nouveau genre il
faut qu'on trouve le monde caché je
détruirai tout ce à quoi tu tiens
tu n'es rien sentons dragon
c'est du riz mais elle arrive à ses fins
les dragons vont disparaître et c'est à
nous de l'arrêté coûte que coûte et donc
qu'est ce que tu vas faire maintenant
dragone c'est parti c'est notre seule
chance
carnet un bébé dans une bataille j'ai
pas trouvé de baby sitter
le nombre cassé il existe vraiment c'est
un roi
tu as raison mon grand il est temps
lourd
tient rigueur nous y voilà
où
[Musique]
je ne veux rien entendre